a scary thought the next time you hail a
taxi maybe getting in a car with an open
safety recall in many of the nation's
biggest cities there are no laws
requiring taxi companies to fix cabs
after safety recalls now the center for
auto safety is calling for change first
on CBS this morning we can tell you the
organization has sent letters demanding
taxicab fleets be required to address
all open safety recalls before they
carry passengers Kris Van Cleave went to
one of the cities affected good morning
the Baltimore area has nearly a thousand
cabs picking up passengers now they're
required to get an annual inspection by
the state of Maryland but the only way a
rider would know if any of these cabs
have an open safety recall for a defect
would be to pull the VIN number before
they got in and Baltimore is not alone
a review by the center for auto safety
found the more than 35 thousand cabs
licensed in nine of the 10 US cities
with the most taxis are not required by
their regulators to get safety recalls
fixed before picking up passengers
there's no way for a customer note
center for auto safety executive
director Jason Levine found only San
Francisco requires cabs to be screened
for recalls there are no cosmetic
recalls recalls are only done for safety
reasons defects or violation of
standards but in your mind this is
something that should get addressed in
my mind yes there are potential safety
concerns here the Maryland Public
Service Commission regulates cabs in
Baltimore transportation director
Christopher corner says the center's
letter has prompted a review of the
state's regulations safety is paramount
as far as looking at the safety recalls
it's complicated that's why we want to
take a deeper dive but is it complicated
can't the state of Maryland say you as a
licensed taxicab operator have to do
this we certainly can and again that's
why we're very much interested in
looking at this last year CBS affiliate
WUSA found as many as one in six
Washington DC cabs had open safety
recalls including for a defective Takata
airbags which have killed at least 24
people worldwide
it's not fair for the unsuspecting
public Kalli Howick knows the danger of
unrepaired recalls both her daughter's
died in a vine
and crash after a recalled power
steering hose broke starting a fire in
their rental car you don't get over it
what you do is you get through it and it
remains with you till you die it never
goes away accidents caused by an
unrepaired safety defect are not
directly tracked so it's impossible to
know how many injuries are even deaths
are related to them the Center for auto
safety has called on companies like uber
and lyft to require their drivers to
also fix open safety recalls before
taking passengers the center says so far
that hasn't happened for CBS this
morning Kris Van Cleave Baltimore it's
such a frightening story I mean under
control you really want to know that if
you're getting into one of these
vehicles that it's checked out and the
fact that it's not in some cases pretty
scary what he said at the end what Kris
said at the end they're also about the
uber and the lyft same thing you ever
get in one of those and then there's an
issue it's shaky and you say you know
what I'm getting out of here good way to
go
you